[Music]
here at jk news we're not uh
we're not virgins to these type of
articles we've uh versions of funny
words yeah what
context i'm not born again virgin what i
dedicated my life got a hymen again
i put it back in my butthole i heard you
got a hybrid bro
two and one diamond heard you got the
surgery
abstinence community
okay and i decided i'm gonna choose
abstinence for how long froze you don't
jack it when she's not here
no i mean like
abstinence
okay
hold on i jack up i just don't have sex
that's tight man let's give joe a round
of applause
and then every day after i i fail and
every day i fail
i fail
but you're failing right now
i failed this morning yeah
that's why he was late he was late hey
dude it's like being an alcoholic i'm
trying to [ __ ] connect with you guys
all right i got a [ __ ] problem
no
i'm trying to say that i right now i'm
not an alcoholic you're calling me an
alcoholic
i'm a little attacked right now i'm
saying just saying like you know like
alcoholics they'll [ __ ] drink alcohol
and be like okay i'm not alcoholic
anymore today i'm gonna [ __ ] be
abstinent right with the alcohols okay
that's what i'm talking about choosing
sobriety so as a as of 10 a.m this
morning
absolutely no yeah that's at 10 a.m yeah
yeah yeah yeah because before that you
[ __ ] you was busting nice
i'm glad we gave you that round of
applause to be nice so uh three
influencers that has sex we're sent to
prison well who is it the business are
three influencers oh okay good we're
sent to prison over three years for over
three years
after pranking a taxi driver stop with
the pranks yo i [ __ ] hate pranks stop
what he's probably like what was the
prank what country would do this russia
russia in russia you can't prank in
russia though they're pranking a taxi
driver in russia by pretending to steal
his car oh [ __ ] off that's not a prank
bro
there's actually some people i think
breaking amongst friends is cool but man
how is that a prank that's like walking
into a liquor store with a ski mask and
a [ __ ] gun
and then they're like let's [ __ ]
prank this dude
and then the cops come and then they're
like that looks like a robbery it's a
prank bro see that's the camera that's
no follow-through they gotta follow all
the way through setting someone's house
on fire and then blowing up it was just
a break
here's your frame you don't have to deal
with this afterwards can you sign this
uh please thank you don't mind the charm
it's just a prank bro so after uh
calling it over a cab to pick them up
they asked the driver to open the trunk
and while the cabbie was opening the the
trunk one of the people got um involved
got into the car uh into the driver's
seat and started driving away
big whoop right despite returning the
vehicle minutes later the driver had
already informed the police yeah i would
i'd immediately call the cops and be
like yo i'm having the worst day of my
life these [ __ ] just stole my
[ __ ] taxi cab yeah one of the
bloggers was in the car filmed the
incident including the driver's reaction
and it's believed that this isn't the
first prank that they pulled and
authorities opted to sentence them to
three years and six months in prison
this this is not the first crime they've
committed yeah
it's funny because if if i was that cab
driver i would want to prosecute even
harder if i found out it was a prank for
social media that makes you more pissed
yeah i wish it was just a regular jacket
i could do this or if at the very least
it's like well maybe this guy needed it
more than i did to provide for his
family or some [ __ ] at the very least
but now this [ __ ] is just doing it for
clout they're taking away your
money-making machine you mean to tell me
you're not much russian mob
yo if that was the russian mob though
those kids would be [ __ ] dead
did you imagine like
the [ __ ] the [ __ ] instead of
getting rolled up on by the police like
it's you like stole from the mob oh
you're just dead then
[ __ ] man so um
authorities say that these three people
were found guilty of committing a crime
under paragraph two blah blah blah
they were sentenced to real imprisonment
for a period of three years and six
months with serving punishment in a
general regime penal colony okay keno
colonies and penal condoms that sounds
like some work cap [ __ ] yeah regime
sounds crazy as [ __ ] exactly it's it's
send them to the gulags dude
yeah that's a gulag for sure you lag i
mean realistically uh
this is russia so not only is the
sentence like for real but like the
punishment and the is probably for real
for it you should punish even harder
when it's a simulation of the crime
being done as a prank
like you should get punished for
advertising people for fun yeah
because then something's [ __ ] wrong
with you man like 100
well let's make them scared they uh
figured out the scientific method [ __ ]
around find out
it's believed it's believed that the uh
yeah
that the influencers will likely be sent
to a prison camp yeah roughly 500
kilometer kilometers from moscow the
publications say that the camps are old
and in a bad state why is it so
satisfying this is a gulag by the way
generally the gulags are built in small
towns where it's difficult to access in
case anyone wanted to try a shawshank
and it's reported that the prisons
generally house around 800 inmates and
live in barracks of around 120 people
sleeping at rain arrangements involved
bunk beds and rooms that were built to
hold 50 or 60 and allegedly there's only
one bathroom with one toilet and one
sink per barrack damn
set the [ __ ] example i love it [ __ ]
around three and a half years you can't
be doing that [ __ ] in russia though dude
where could you do it and get away with
it [ __ ] here you ass here of course
that [ __ ] they don't give a [ __ ] man i
do hate like canada pranks though uk
oh i think that there's like tears to
bring pranks right there's obviously
ones that are so clearly like just like
simple funny and don't like put somebody
else in inconvenience or harm yeah or
danger in or danger right or like really
[ __ ] with somebody's day and then
there's like
pranks that are just stupid like they're
those those are pranks like this this is
not a prank that's that's it's crime
yeah that's like returning the [ __ ]
you should like you guys said you guys
should probably just drive away with the
real you got cold feet no follow through
if you're gonna do it just steal it
you're saying that they're just bad
criminals yeah they're bad criminals you
know who i like uh he's an old school
prankster
um red
so he would just have characters and he
would do like harmless ones
yeah one would be like he had this guy
to be like look at this car
just look at it and he would say that
non-stop to a guy that has a car and
let's say he has a regular car and the
guy gets all like yeah yeah man
yeah and he gets super happy and that's
all you would say over and over just
look at this car would you look at you
weren't you looking and it's just the
it's so funny how the guys react yeah
and there's another one where he had
like a fake bee on his nose and then he
would come up to strangers and be like b
and then the people were trying to help
him and [ __ ] goes pee
yeah that's like harmless like no one's
getting hurt it's harmless
that's [ __ ] harm that's sort of like
pickup lines or some [ __ ] didn't you
[ __ ] do like pokemons ucla or
something like that like things like
that like if anything like it's harmless
doesn't hurt anybody yeah if anything it
flatters somebody you don't know what's
your best pickup line i don't remember
did it so long it was so hard whereas
like when i when i like scroll down on
my feed and i randomly see those people
that are like in the aisles of like
grocery stores or like
that and then they like take like a bag
of like dough or something and they
throw it on somebody and then they
pretend like it's happening to them yeah
i'm like
i get the mechanics of what makes this a
prank but i'm like
that also [ __ ] sucks for this
innocent bystander yeah and the [ __ ]
worker got to clean your [ __ ] off yeah
especially at a store bro i don't like
that [ __ ] dog oh you know which ones i
see that i'm just like this is funny in
in in concept but if i worked here this
would annoy the [ __ ] you know those
ones where they're like oh i lived in
walmart for like 18 hours or something
where they like crawl inside like make a
fort inside of something and i'm like
oh dude like if that was me like i knew
and i had to close the store up or
something like that and i have to like
try and [ __ ] find these idiots like
being inside i'm like come on bro like
i'm making minimum wage that's slightly
in the second tier where i still think
that's a little bit funny to be
completely honest yeah it's a little bit
funny but when i think about it more
than i become more like
so you guys have never run into like a
youtube prankster in real life no have
you yeah i mean me and hawk were eating
at a grand central market outside and
then this [ __ ] guy it's like so
obvious he comes with he's like dressed
like a waiter and he comes with a
[ __ ] pepper grinder and he's like
would you like some pepper for your food
and he starts about to grind it and me
and hawk are both like
don't post this one man this one sucks
[Music]
we were just like we were just like dude
this one's not this is not even good and
like you can see he just walked away and
like his camera guy's all left like
could you also tell him like i don't
consent to being on no we didn't even
get that it was like a second
interaction but they're probably they
said it sucks guys hey guys they didn't
wrap it up
this is this one this just sucks bro
like he just was like
i've been discovered and just like went
to another place to do it because we
were like would you like some pepper
that's so stupid dude have you seen the
guys like they're i don't know
they're like foreign i don't know where
they're from like eastern european or
something and they're in new york and
they go to the hood
and they're like we're gonna prank the
hood i think they do this in l.a too and
they get the [ __ ] kicked out of them all
the time
he was tying his shoes
he goes up to him holds his head down to
his butt has a fart button
presses it
the guy gets he he looks up and and he
starts immediately bombing on him
because that's what he deserves whether
it's a real fart or not and he's like
and the whole time that's when they're
like it's a break it's a prank but
they're getting the [ __ ] kicked out of
them those videos make me very happy
yeah those are funny those are great and
they still posted it
there's a recent one that maybe really
smile it's like a it's like a group of
homies like like four or five like thug
looking like black dudes right and
they're just like walking around but
then they'll just go up to a random
group and then they'll just like pretend
to take like a nice photo and that
person is just like
i'm like that's [ __ ] tired so people
get mad that's cool which which even
then i'm like that's still like a very
like non harmful or inconvenient style
situation i feel like just take the
picture why not yeah it's a slight it
might be a slight invasion of like
privacy or comfort in that moment i can
understand somebody like but it's a good
spirit though i think yeah it stays in
good spirit versus like [ __ ] throwing
like [ __ ] dough at you or something
you know or like the milk jugs i think
all those people should be set on fire
have you seen those they go in a grocery
store they throw on the floor and i'm
like you should be shot in the face i
think i think that's equal i think
that's equal you know there's this guy
that goes up to like all the asian asian
people and he just goes like
like that in the ear or something yeah
did you see that one guy turned around
and tried to [ __ ] his ass up he hate
that guy too see that [ __ ] too yeah and
and this had nothing to do with the
prank but this is just funny random
stuff back in the day uh i think when we
were living at taj mahal um
for
what was the name of our college house i
feel like i'm missing a couple pieces of
this puzzle
for a halloween party i think it might
have been like mike in a couple like you
know a couple of other i should not say
first and last time um couple of the
college zombies for halloween they're
like what do we do what do we do for uh
uh you know halloween costume or
whatever so last minute they decided to
do uh like girls gone wild costumes so
they were like orange t-shirts they took
like a mop stick and they put like uh
the end of like what looked like a fake
um boom mic and stuff moving around with
like a fake camera [ __ ] it's pretty
funny but it was like really funny so we
would like party hop and they were
trying to go to the parties and actually
remember like uh people at the door be
like you guys aren't allowed in here
just really thinking they're actually
girls gone wild and they would get
denied from like two or three parties
because it was just a costume that was a
genius costume i remember i remember
that yeah girls got wild film crew and
then they had like even someone with a
clipboard with like papers it was
nothing it was like written with
sharpies like lawrence girl's gone wild
but imagine being that bouncer like let
you in and then it shows up later on tv
and then you're like who the [ __ ] was
manning the door that night
it's like they wrote it on their [ __ ]
shirts bro
[Music]
you